kind of Fe ahead Dan forth breaks that up and
away go to the Blue Jackets good row at Center
trying to lead fanil into the deep into the Zone
lid gets a piece of the scramble in front Martin
Jones down covers up with the blue paint and Jones
I know he's a better player but he's only played
five games on the season and this one G it's just
a little bit of difficulty on this play you can
see how it's driven up the ice and towards the
net by Fant from the face side battle ensues in
that near circle from behind the net marer turns
and it was tipped there by Matthews but Tracked
Down Riley throws it into the corner Matthew n
tried to get a stick on it from the rightwing
wall Matthew n did not play in Toronto in the
game between the two teams 10 nights ago Puck
it oh teras up every shift singer has really
come on riding a two- game goal scoring streak
and Kent Johnson we talked about him his game has
been elevated a sharp ankles shot off the stick
there of Gregor and the jackets have sent it to
scooping up the puck P Johnson throws it in deep
Johnson had two goals including the gamewinner
of his first three-point game in Toronto long
shot here sailes wide Martin Jones looking behind
him it's thrown into the slot from behind the net
Jones now just getting back up on his feet some
anxious moments around the Toronto net and here
he'll just hold little Christmas movie for Kent
Johnson and Adam fony last night watching Home
Alone there's the shot redirected too early so he
really wasn't driving up Ice Matthew sends it in
goes right back after it caral it sends it to the
point here Ry with a shot deflected rebound terasa
gets a piece of that with the PS real sharp ear
nice sequence here for terasa it's this initial
play see the deflection now how does he get that
pat out that quick he just adjust himself right
there and marner's trying to beat him to it it's
a Rolling Puck that Marner just wants to get that
stick on and here comes marchenko and a dance
away there from knives protects that puck feels
it in the corner Andrew Peak now a left wing pass
baronov drops it back pu turned over circling the
net this is marer Marner now hanging on quick
shot scores what a pass and Austin Matthews
the National Hockey League's leading goal scorer
adds to his total now at 27 here's the play as
Pete can't connect with baronov see baronov there
he goes back to the middle of the ice and that's
where Marr says okay I'll take it now he's waiting
for Matthews to get open see that little clutch
the double clutch he misses that first attempt
to get it across but then he makes sure he gets
it Austin Matthews and that's where Matthew just
said yeah you knew what I was thinking and you
made it happen on the coinci miners Puck turned
over neutral ice getting it back this is neander
looking to cut in does tried to tuck it home went
right through the blue paint Camp sends it over on
the backand dad for looking to come up with that
puck knocked away from him kept in by the Leafs
behind the net walks out cers and the Pu rifled
wider than that while the doctors were in there
and that's when the good news came out from Todd
sherat jacket's public relations department it
was all for precaution and cor would be checked
out by the doctors here a breakway moving right
SC Jack TI It Up does it again he's playing on
that Top Line but look at this as the map Le are
making the way up the ice it's just a clear that
comes right up in the middle and here's Johnny
he's got turned towards him and then Dan on the
back he puts it right there for him and he gets
it nice little move right up top over Jones
scub and the blue Jacks have tied it up here
111 early what a pass by Zack rinsky oh what a
play to turn that puck over on neander as well
exactly tavarus comes off the wall fires a shot
and scores a spinner raama and
then he beats tarus top shelf
see the time and space four on four it's a
man-on-man situation and John dearis here
finds a little daylight and somehow gets that
to his forehead I think he was surprised as
well you got three Blue Jackets around him
and then he just decides to pull away and
shoot and as neanders in front with Zack rensy
that terasa can't pick it up here's Kent Johnson
threw it across the line works on Camp still
with it looks cross ice bemstrom with a golden
opportunity Morgan Riley Austin Matthews
looking down low Taris save terce up again
and he hears from the crowd little more than
30 seconds left here's another attempt and
it sails High Matthews to pick it up this
crowd electric here right now appreciating
the effort here by the jackets on the kill
Taris 20 seconds left far side of the ice
Marner sends it up high neander Marner Marner
cross ice Matthews power play goal is second of
the night 28th of the season and his eighth
power PL tally you can see John Deus on the
spin here that's defenseman Morgan Riley up in
the play now as Marr's going to get this back
from neander he's looking across that team and
he finds it and Austin Matthews he scores from
everywhere Jeff but that's his bread and butter
it's that quick release he's got one like that
already tonight from mner and here is just
a high hard release upstairs three fet side
wow traffic in front that was baronov to the
side of the net fires the shot Martin Jones
is there he dropped the gloves with this guy he
could do some damage Zack rinsky with that keep
in earlier but then this is the play from that
where chikov tries to get it to ronov clean he
doesn't got update Coral he's got an abdominal
issue he will not return tonight does not appear
to be serious but he is taking to Grant Medical
Center for further evaluation there's your
update you certainly wish Sean caral wellis
yeah that's a good update after seeing Sean
carow leave in that first period And there's a
teras Ops looking at good Push by him and then
Riley had blocked that shot chov back to riny
from marchenko baronov sets that big screen in
front Johnny gdo in the right wing baronov in
the slot Marko save and the rebound gathered up
he just gets faked out with this passing attempt
here's that play in the middle of marenko here he
has that second chance hustling here is Dad boy
to the right wing Corner McCade gets a stick on
it this is neander it's a two-on one neander
across the line with TJ Brody and NE keeps
and scores a short-handed goal with 16 seconds
remaining in the Columbus power play oh neander
there I mean it's a two-on-one short-handed
and teras off swept away but now a turnover
you can see neander right there he waited he
waited he waited waited for terasoft to move
a little bit and when he did little daylight
you can see how terasa was loading up for the
push Point streaks twice for neander out of
the box comes doy doy on a breakaway blocks
in and terasa gets a piece of it Barner across
the line on to Taris pressured there by marenko
who chips in ahead hustles to the puck he's got
chinab with him marchenko fights off the check
Martin Jones makes the save he looked behind
him I wasn't too confident Rick oh yeah that
puck cleared but he wasn't confident that
it went out of play individual effort here
marchenko not sure where that shot went
maybe we'll get a better look at it here
here he comes looks like it went right off the
mask well that last game that third
period is one of their best there's
some good hockey to be played but
right now tonight they leave at
home against the Toronto Maple who
come here under the uh performance